اذا المشاهدين مع اقتراب موسم ذروه
الاجازات نتعرف على وجهات صيف غير متوقعه
او ربما متوقعه يمكنك اخذها بعين الاعتبار
للسفر في 2023 وذلك بحسب سي ان ان ليفربول
انجلترا في يونيو ستحتفل مدينه بمرور 25
عاما على مهرجان الفنون البصريه المعاصره
حيث يتولى اكثر من 30 فنانا المساحاتا في
المدينه حتى سبتمبر رواندا شهدت هذا العام
الافتتاح الرسمي للفندق الاكثر اثاره وهو
عباره عن مجموعه من الاكواخ المصنوعه بشكل
تقليدي على جزيره عند بحيره اكبر البحيرات
في افريقيا
جوتنبرغ في السويد اختيرت كالوجه الاكثر
استدامه في العالم لمده 6 اعوام على
التوالي وهي الان واحده من اكثر وجهات
خضره في اوروبا
وخمسه وتسعون بالمئه من فنادقها صديقه
للبيئه القاهره في مصر رغم ان اهرامات
الجيزه هي المعلم الجاذب للمدينه لانه لا
يزال هناك المزيد لرؤيته خاصه مع توقعات
افتتاح المتحف المصري الكبير هذا العام
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات